auch bei der verleihung der wichtigsten
musikpreise der welt dürfte das thema
donald trump nicht fehlt bei der
grammy-verleihung in new york larsen
starmusiker aus dem umstrittenen
tönungsfolie von michael wolf vor in dem
der us präsidenten seine familie alles
andere als gut wegkommen die
aufgezeichnete lesung wurde begleitet
von den launigen kommentaren von
moderator james corden von einem
millionen publikum gesehen
unter anderem lasen john legend
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die band im 19
und auch eine politikerin war bei der
lesung dabei der demokraten hillary
clinton die bei der präsidentenwahl
gegen tram verloren hatte machte das
offenbar viel spaß
[Applaus]
dass er und wurde das turnier 62
hinderer